no no no don't turn it over again Jameis
not again hello Jameis I'm not supposed
to talk to strangers or media or my
teammates franchise the dependable clown
would you like to join me
Oh your decision-making just naturally
put you in the sewer okay haven't seen
you guys since our work a year why now
evil clown is back is gonna terrorize
gridiron Heights with you'll never
defeat me sorry can Diego stole my 2004
is our last movie I don't you I don't
just run through each other so question
it were just a PlayStation app
justification for it the best place to
play ah can't frickin believe we gotta
save the GD day again what's this
no no it's dangerous to run hey this
change man go now well you know maybe I
could start but now
look at that real you'll never be
feeling special hey what's new with you
don't get to play weak you're mine
Mariota it's not real I think that's
actually right pan out this way okay
well Larry he's clearly a Hall of Famer
a light has the Rings consistency it's
me Matt Schaub
also 2004 draft class 2040 lot I'm a
Hall of Famer to my friends okay so rj+
we'll just stay here if you liked this
video subscribe below for more we done
okay thanks yeah I'm so scared all the
time I see goes schools goblins sand
you're still might saw some vampires
ones very spooky I think I'm very
haunted